quite quickly have realized I've always
known that I've never never been the
best recruiter like I've never been in a
room full of recruiters and thinking I'm
the best and then I got lucky enough to
like work with some really good people
when I ended up in the leadership role
I'm in now early days who were way
better than I ever was and all I was
thinking if they turn up like motivated
engaged happy to come to work proud that
they work with me with this business
like that's all I've got to do like I've
just got to get them out of bed and be
like I'm excited to go to work if I get
that bit right because they're so good
at their job like I don't necessarily
have to touch too much else